what okay number three though I've
always been shocked that Stein gate was
this highly rated because I [__] love
Stein gate don't get me wrong but I just
don't see it as a show that has just as
much of a mainstream appeal as
Brotherhood I don't think this is
mainstream though this is my anime list
yeah so my anime list has has this this
weird kind of thing that I noticed that
I'm sure will'll keep coming to this
list right certain shows get rated very
highly among uh people who spend their
on this website uh and I think
steinsgate is pretty much the peak
example of a perfect my anime list
viewer show uh that is true I my anime
list fans are like what Rick and Morty
fans were like five years ago where
they're like you don't have a big enough
I you're not smart enough to understand
Stein gate and I kind of think like in a
weird way they like steinsgate appeals
very much the kind of person who enjoys
using my anime list and like kind of
Internet forums yeah yeah not say it's
not a good show but I think that it
would it's a show that I think would
rate very highly amongst people like
that yeah because I feel like my anime
list is the perfect representation of
someone who is like one tier like goes
one tier deeper than let's say like the
shown and mega popular shows uh so it's
at like that second tier of like okay
this is what happens after you explore
anime when you have just gone out of
like Mega popular shownin but not so
much you you haven't reach the deeper
tear of just like the oo I'm watching
all you know something cerebr I'm to
keep in mind right this is this is like
a social network so people feel like
almost judged based on what they're
presenting so you know when if you have
a list well you can't you can't have
Stein skate you can't not watch Stein
skate not have it at a 10 I mean I guess
there is that social pressure so you we
have to really think about how this
interacted in this sense and I think
Stein skate is that an example where I
think if you say you've watched this and
you don't rate it highly then there's
something wrong with you what would you
rate sign say out of 10 uh got feeling
go got feeling I would give it like a
nine I think the only reason what would
you put it uh so can we do decimal
points okay fine okay okay if we're
going decimal points I'd give it like an
8.5 yeah same 8. I think the start of
science gate is too slow yes uh and it
really hurts the show in general um this
is definitely not a show I think that
it's difficult to recommend right
because obviously the first 10 11
episodes are so incredibly slow and it
really have you tried rewatching it I
have tried rewatching it it's tough It's
really it's really tough even though I
know everything that's happening and I
know the reason why they're taking their
time with it because obviously it all
it's all necessary information and
details that pays off in the second half
and especially the ending but like
having that kind of format in anime I
think is a format that just doesn't
really work nowadays because people I
just think have I don't want to say they
have less of an attention span or
anything but I think I think I think the
whole appeal of slow burner shows is
slowly dying out you have to you can you
can do slow Burns but you have to really
be smart with how you do it
nowadays Slow Burn shows like what what
is slow burer show that was
like fre SL free it's like slow bur is
such like a to me it's it's it feels
like such a backed compliment yeah it's
you know what I mean where I can't say
it in
but also could also mean like hey they
trust you as a viewer to to stay with
these people just maybe just talking
yeah oh and that is Stein gate to the
tea right and I cuz there to me there's
a difference between let's say something
that is a slow burn and something that
let's say has a slower Pace but is still
compelling you know to me like you know
Game of Thrones is just talking yeah
yeah yeah exactly that's the best of
Game of Thrones when they're just
talking and you're like the drama here
yeah where you know there is a lot of
drama there and there is not so much
happening in terms of like plot
progression but it's just compelling to
watch right whereas with Stein gate the
first half I feel that's I this to me is
just slow it's not like I can see the
characters I'm not so much compelled
with what's happening there's not so
much plot progression but I'm not as
invested and then it hits you about
halfway through and then there is this
point that it grabs you and it just does
not let go and uh to me I wouldn't call
it a SLO but it's definitely not as
enjoyable I'd call it a SLO would you
call it a SLO I can't remember I I
distinctly remember I I had downloaded
to watch it and I had it and I I had a
few other shows to watch and every
single time I tried to watch it I
couldn't finish the first episode
without being like come on see for me it
was like I eventually did get around to
doing it but it was tough for me it gets
tough around like episode 6 or seven cuz
like the first couple of episodes okay
you understand yeah you understand
because there there's so much new
information that they're throwing to the
viewer right like oh we have the
microwave we have the banana we have the
pH happens right and then around episode
6 or 7 is when you start to get to the
point where it's like is this going to
be like this for the entire series I get
if like the first couple of episodes are
slow and then it starts picking up but
when you get like six seven episodes
deep and it's at going at that pace then
you're just like o I'm starting to lose
a bit of faith that anything interesting
is going to happen and then obviously
around I think it was episode 12 or 13
that thing happen that's crazy but this
is also different cuz animes used to be
just longer back then yeah so I feel
like if Stein came out now I almost
think it could be even better because
they' probably have like a 13 15 episode
run and it they cut out all the bu cut
[__] maybe they they through they
get through it faster maybe they they
actually do cut stuff that maybe did
actually just slow down the story but
see then I would argue will the impact
be the same I think it could I think the
impact could be the same I I don't think
you have to give as much time um for it
to have the same impact I don't know
maybe I'm wrong though I could be
totally wrong like like to me I watch
this like [__] eight years ago yeah I
want to I want to get the opinion of
someone like like an anime View today
who has never seen this show here's the
thing I don't think
it here's the thing we watched it like
eight or so years ago right yeah 2011
last anime like there was like the the
top list back then was 50 Max and then
you'd be like okay I can I can actually
feasibly watch all of the great animes
yeah and I still like I still think in
this day the after the turning point it
still would like hit as hard but I I
think the beginning portion would be
even like would have aged even worse
than when we watched it because this
came out at a time when let's say otaku
kind of like otaku culture shows didn't
weren't as prevalent in like the anime
Community right do you remember this and
it was like it was It was kind of fun
the the the big appealing part for me
with Stein gate the beginning part was
that oh it's like set in akih harra yo
they're wee yo this guy's a for CH would
be a bit cringe
nowadays he would be a bit cringe yeah
yeah yeah to to me Stein gate the
characters are so [__] anime you you
know what I mean when
when oh yeah mayi oh my God they're just
very very very anime also the first show
that burned the cicada noise into my
brain the entire series I totally agree
but like one thing I do think I has aged
well is that to this day I can't think
of any or many other shows that they
have time travel as like a mechanic and
it feels like they tie up every single
knot in its own time travel Mechanic In
A satisfying way incredibly well thought
out story and the ending is very
satisfying it was originally a visual
novel if you [__] feel it in the
start that's for sure yeah yeah because
like even with something like you know
Attack on Titan or most other time
travel shows there's like you can think
of like some plot holes you watch it and
you're like H that kind of didn't make
sense but after watching Stein's gate I
can't think of any other time travel
show where where I thought to myself man
that just made sense they they they
covered everything I guess cuz it was
the only kind of mechanic in the show
that they were exploring which which
really allows you to get really
interesting with it yeah also they were
also they based a lot of the ideas off
of the previous game in the semicolon
series which is a Chaos Head which is
semicolon series that is what it's
called the semicolon universe so cuz
they had Chaos Head Stein's gate
robotics notes and uh occultic 9 and
they were all done by the same company
and like a lot of the ideas from Stein
gate were based off Chaos Head chaos
head is not good by the way don't watch
it do you think Stein gate is overrated
then I think it's I think it's I think
it's properly rated um but then again
that might be my Nostalgia talking uh
because I remember when this was airing
and I would watch this weekly and it was
the most insane [__] yeah this was the
most insane [__] I'd ever watched uh
just hearing you talk about anime then
especially the the semicolon series I
don't even know what that was
if we did trash taste 10 years ago how
much of a different show this would been
would it would actually be anime you
actually would be you'd be such a nerd
dude dude I haven't brought up the
semicolon Series in a long time I I know
my [__] also I will say the [__]
Stein's gate opening still a banger I
don't care what anyone says [__]
hacking to the gate how does it how does
that
go cuz to me Full Metal Alchemist the
[__] Brotherhood the first opening
that again by Yi yeah that was such that
was a banger I know was
like is that the one yeah that's yeah
that's it
[Music]
okay I don't want to see it CU copyright